director and we'll be joined later today
by our director Shafi goldblusser and
we're also joined by numerous staff
members including Omid Farr and the
video Booth back there Kalani Penland
Carson young and behind the scenes
William homnicky and Amy Ambrose and
we're all here to welcome you to the
eighth annual assignments industry day
I want to thank you for joining us
um and for your participation in the
life and the Simon's Institute whether
you're an industry partner a program
organizer a scientific collaborator or
research fellow you're all making
important to important contributions to
our work here so we thank you for that
our mission here at the Simons Institute
is to provide a collaborative platform
for research and Computing Theory and
related fields and we host diverse
populations of scientists engineers
mathematicians and experts in other
related appeals including social
sciences economics and the law
um thanks to community members like you
um we're able to facilitate uh impactful
and deep research and we thank you for
your many contributions
so we have a really full schedule today
uh lightning Talks by research fellows
and Industry Partners followed by a
networking launch
um and then we'll hear uh from three
Institute programs and their organizers
um and then we'll hear about exciting
new research on a project funded by the
algorand foundation
and uh then we'll have a special session
at the end on data-driven decision
processes and finally we will proceed to
dinner at The Faculty Club
so I hope you have access to the um
digital events booklet because that has
important information including
schedules speaker names titles abstracts
there's a lot of information going to be
given to you today so if you want to
revisit any of that much of today's
content will be available on our YouTube
channel
um so I want to give a special thanks to
our industry partners for supporting our
work through the year uh our current
list of Industry Partners include
algorand Apple Google
JPMorgan NTT research PayPal rock360 and
VMware and we're always open to adding
more Partners to our community so please
let us know if you'd like more
information about that and finally I'd
like to uh thank our dedicated staff for
making today's events possible and
before I invite the first speaker to the
uh the podium I want to point out an
important person today who's our Carson
our timekeeper
um so you'll speakers you'll need to
play special attention to Carson and
research fellows as you know we have
allocated five minutes to each of you so
this is a tight timeline but I think
you're up to the challenge please pay
attention to Carson she's going to give
you a one minute warning so your five
minutes includes questions
um and uh at the end of your talk please
introduce reduce the next speaker
there's a list of speakers underneath
the laptop
so please introduce the next speaker and
their title
um
and our first fellow is ziv Scully and
his talk is on New Practical lessons
from queuing and scheduling Theory
foreign
so uh thank you Sandy uh it's it's great
to be here today uh I'm I'm excited to
sort of uh basically kind of be part of
this collaboration between Simons and
Industry and so it's what I'm going to
tell you about today in this sort of
very quick talk is oh I'm not really
going to tell you about any practical
lessons from queuing and scheduling and
Theory but I'm going to tell you that
there are new practical lessons from
queuing and scheduling Theory and I'm
going to give you a sense of the sorts
of uh problems that these lessons are
about
um so the sort of core question that I
that I've been thinking about over the
course of my thesis is how do we
schedule jobs to minimize delay and
these are jobs in all sorts of queuing
systems so I'm mostly motivated by
computer systems so you might think
about
um a network switch that has several
packet flows that it needs to transmit
or a database that has queries arriving
over time that it needs to process I'm
going to abstract away from the details
of exactly what this system is and I'm
gonna I sort of study cubing systems in
the abstract so this is a server jobs
are arriving over time to get work done
at the server and so the server can make
progress on jobs jobs keep arriving over
time
and then um once the job leaves the
amount of time it's spent in the system
I'm going to call that the job's
response time
and this is the sort of quantity uh that
I'm thinking of as delay right so when
I'm trying to minimize delay I'm trying
to minimize some Metric related to
response time for example mean response
time that the average response time
across all jobs in the sequence
okay and so and so what do I mean by
scheduling I mean choosing which job to
serve at each moment in time and the key
idea when you're trying to minimize mean
response time is you want to serve short
jobs in front of long jobs the intuition
is that you create less total weighting
by having the long job wait the short
amount of time than vice versa
okay and if you're kind of taking this
idea to its technological conclusion if
a short job arrives while you're serving
a long job then you should preempt the
long jump
that is pause it switch it out for the
short one and start doing that
and so this gives you a policy called
shortest remaining processing time at
every moment in time server whichever
drop is the least remaining and this is
optimal for minimizing mean response
time okay so I asked this question at
the top of the slide and I gave you an
answer srpt so uh why is that not the
end of the few right why and the answer
is there's lots of reasons we might not
use srpt either we don't want to use
srpt or we can't use srpt in practice so
for example one reason we can't use srpt
is if we don't know which jobs are short
and which jobs are long if we have
unknown job sizes so this might look
something like this where uh you know
you might be doing a database query you
know how much work you've done already
so you know kind of the progress but you
might not know how much is left because
you don't know how many rows are going
to make it through this scan blah blah
blah so lots of settings in practice
with unknown job sizes
um another reason we might not want to
do srpt is we might have a multi-server
system so this optimality result for
srpt has been proven for single server
systems what if you're in a multi server
system is srpt still a good idea does
something go wrong
another reason we might not be able to
do srpt is if we have some sort of
preemption limitations so this might be
something like overhead something like
you can't preempt jobs at every moment
in time here's a sort of interesting
type of preemption limitation that comes
up in computer systems is uh so you can
think of srpt as sort of prioritizing
jobs continuously right as a jobs uh
remaining size decreases its priority
gets better and better continuously
but in many computer systems you can't
do this so for example in a network
switch when you buy a network switch it
has some number of priority levels built
into the hardware like four or eight
so you can if you want to implement srbt
you have to sort of bucket things so how
how should you choose the bucket
boundaries how many buckets do you need
how expensive of the network switch do
you need to buy to get good scheduling
okay and then lastly a reason we might
not want to do srpt is we might not care
about mean response time we might care
about other metrics instead or in
addition
uh so we might care about the tale of
response time percentiles
um other other things
and so and so these are obstacles we
face in practice and the sort of problem
I've been working on is that we don't
have the scheduling and human Theory to
address these obstacles and so what is
my research agenda is basically
developing new tools and queuing and
scheduling Theory to address these
obstacles uh in my thesis I have two of
these tools that have cute names like
soap and wine
um and the sort of impact uh that I'm
excited to sort of talk with you all uh
talk with you all uh throughout the day
is that
um is that the lessons we learn in the
sort of theorems we prove with these
tools uh actually have nice practical
takeaways and so here are four examples
of these practical takeaways and if
you're interested to hear more uh please
feel free to get in touch or talk with
me throughout the day uh that's it
thanks for your attention
thank you
all right uh so I think uh without
there's not really time for questions so
let's bring up the next speaker who is
Jackie who's going to talk about
exploration for algorithmic fairness
foreign
my name is Jackie so I'm a research
fellow here and I'll be joining NY Stern
as an assistant professor in the next
year uh so I'm interested in sort of
algorithmic fairness and so I'll talk a
bit about sort of one problem in this
space
and so uh at a high level I think of
algorithmic fairness as any time an
algorithm exhibits some sort of
undesirable disparity that could have a
pretty big impact on society
um and so there's many ways that such an
undesirable disparity may arise in
practice but one way that's common uh in
practice is that is the disparity stems
from the data set right because the data
set is kind of unrepresentative of the
population you're interested in uh so to
give you a concrete example in the kind
of a Precision medical setting it is
um it has been shown that there's
actually some concern that there will be
an increase in kind of in inequalities
in healthcare uh because of data sets
because data sets are kind of
non-representative of this population
we're interested in
um and so basically I'm saying that
there's some sort of bias and data
generating process
um but if you look at the literature on
algorithmic fairness most of it will try
to modify the algorithm so that it's
more fair for some definition of
fairness
um but if the underlying issue was with
the data then this is not really going
to solve the original problem
right and so the obvious solution to
this problem is to simply just collect
collect more data right or collect more
representative data
um and so doing this is of course not
always easy but one sort of natural way
to collect more representative data is
to Simply kind of continue collecting
data once you've deployed the algorithm
in practice right so once you've
deployed the algorithm you'll make
decisions but then once you you know
make decisions you'll generate more data
and then you can kind of feed this back
in and then update your algorithm and
sort of this idea of adding this
feedback loop is essentially in the
machine learning space uh it's called
online learning which is a very large
field in machine learning and in online
learning essentially you modify the
algorithm so that it in the future it
will become better and this idea of kind
of obtaining better data is what's
called exploration
so online learning is a very well
studied field and and machine learning
and essentially I'm saying that just
using online learning is actually a way
to tackle problems uh such such problems
In algorithmic fairness
and this is kind of a theoretically
well-backed claim uh but the main
downside of using online learning is the
fact that you have to explore and
exploration kind of by definition is
costly in the short term so what I mean
by exploration so let's take the hiring
setting as an example so in hiring
you're making decisions on who you're
going to hire and you can like learn
about who you know which what kind of
candidates are good so in that in this
setting exploration would refer to
something like you would recruit from a
school that you've never recruited from
before right and so this is going to be
pretty costly because when you go to a
new school you have no idea how to
evaluate these candidates but then once
after you do some kind of exploration
after a while you will learn about
um who who our best candidates to hire
so um so this is an example of
exploration it is costly in the short
term but sort of in the long run
theoretically you will end up hiring
sort of better and better candidates
right so
um so my research so one research
Direction I'm interested in is
understanding and practice whether we
should be kind of exploring right for
example in the hiring setting right and
this is because if you don't if you
don't explore if you just do greedy um
it's well known that you can be stuck at
some local optimal right you just keep
hiring the same type of people that you
hired in the past
um and so there's some recent work that
shows that that has some empirical work
that shows that actually in the hiring
setting you should exploration actually
does improve both the quality and
diversity of new hires
um so a couple questions I have not not
which is not like specific to the hiring
setting but
um you know the question is like our
Real World Systems actually stuck uh due
to being at this local optimal like is
Will real world system actually benefit
from exploration
um and if we do want to explore then how
much kind of cost do we incur like how
much do we have to wait for exploration
to be worth it
um so this is uh kind of one of the
research directions I have but in
general I'm interested in algorithmic
fairness so I'm happy to chat more about
you know different aspects about
algorithmic fairness that you might um
have at your um at your companies and
yeah that's it thanks
uh so the next talk will be by kangning
uh who will be talking about Fair
provision of public goods
foreign
[Applause]
Stanford as a postdoc
so uh in this talk I'm going to talk
about a more concrete problem so uh
consider the following to democratic
processes the first is called
participatory budgeting where let's
imagine a status deciding what projects
to found using its limited budget and
Motors can have different preferences
and they can express their preferences
through their votes and the goal is to
find a fair solution to all the voters
suppose for example some voters may
prefer to build a new park and some
other routers may prefer to build a new
hospital but the city may only have
budgets to build one of them so we need
to design a fair process to find a
solution
another related uh Democratic process is
called committee selection where sales a
country is electing a parliament of a
given number of seats from some
candidates and again voters can have
different preferences and we want to
design a process to Fire Solutions and
we want to point out that these two are
mathematical abstractions that also work
for other settings for example in the
fair clustering problem we want to
select K centers to be fair to all the
data points and as another example in
the fair uh shared caching problem
there's some common space for caching
and we want to design a fair caching
policy to all the processes using that
common space
so we adopt the notion of the car and
the notion of this car is a classical
notion in economics and the general idea
can date back to the 19th century so the
idea is let's say the battery limit has
B and there are involters then we want
each voter to have an equal voting power
of B over n I will say a solution is in
the core if there's no subset of Voters
who can deviate using their own budget
so that each deviating voter is better
off
and if there's no such deviation then we
say a solution is in the court so the
core captures group fairness for all
subsets and it's a strong notion of
fairness so it's not surprising that the
core can actually be empty in many cases
so as computer scientists when something
may not exist we want to provide a
guaranteed approximations to that notion
so we actually can show that constant
approximate core Solutions always exist
in the sense that if each voter only
retains a constant fraction of their
voting power when they deviate then a
core Solutions always exist and that's
another example of if each voter only
deviants to solutions that are much
better to them than core Solutions can
obviously exist as well
so that's all of my talk thanks
so uh foreign
[Music]
hello everyone
um my name is Hara to shade
approximately correctly just ignore the
C in front of it
um I'm a fellow here at UC Berkeley for
the year and then I'm going to join MIT
as an assistant professor of operations
research and statistics
so I'd like to talk to you about my
research which is an incentive aware
machine learning for decision making and
let me just give you an idea of what
this live passwords mean
so I'm sure most of you in this audience
know that machine learning algorithms
are currently being used for decision
making in many consequential
decision-making scenarios so for example
a machine learning algorithm may decide
whether you qualify for a loan or not
whether you will get probation whether
after an interview with a video
interview software you will be invited
for an on-site interview uh and
ultimately be given the job of your
dreams and whether students who apply to
college will be admitted to the colleges
of their choice you know because people
humans know how consequential these
decisions are they oftentimes try to
change the data that they feed into the
machine learning algorithms in an effort
to obtain better outcomes for themselves
so in the loan approval example
uh we see that people sometimes increase
the number of credit cards that they
have uh or try to increase their bank
accounts number of bank accounts that
they have or they improve their credit
history right before uh applying for a
new loan in the college admissions
example we see that students try various
ways to improve their GPA they
oftentimes retake the GRE or pay for
tutoring classes and an interesting
example of strategizing is that they
usually change schools in order to
obtain a better in class right
particular examples so strategizing can
be observed also for the video interview
software case where people only try to
dress a certain way they may try to hide
piercings and tattoos and change the way
that they talk hoping to be perceived as
a different demographic
now I'd like to point out that uh here
when I talk about people changing the
data that they feed into these
algorithms I don't just mean people
gaining the algorithm I also mean people
trying to improve their data to improve
their qualifications for the algorithm
what is the problem here in the general
the problem is that if machine learning
algorithms ignore people's incentives
and their reactive behaviors that they
have then we risk making policy
decisions that are incompatible with the
original policies goal
and this is what my research agenda
tries to tackle under the name of
incentive aware machine learning where I
studied the effects of strategic
behaviors strategic Behavior both to
institutions and society as a whole and
subsequently I try to provide uh
algorithms to adapt to this strategic
behavior of Agents
so every time that uh someone talks
about an incentive aware machine
Learning System I want you to keep in
mind that there are three key
stakeholders uh that we think about
the first stakeholder uh is the
institution the institutions are the
mechanism or algorithm designers for
example their school the justice system
the company what not uh the actions they
can take is that they deploy learning
algorithms in order to predict
accurately the future and the goals are
various they can strive for justice they
can strive for better profits and so on
so forth
the second stakeholder is the individual
the individuals are people the data
providers who Supply their data uh to
these algorithms and they are judged by
these algorithms the goal of people of
individuals is to get the best outcomes
for themselves so in the loan approval
example when you're applying for a loan
you want to get a loan
and the actions that you can take is
that you can try to change your data uh
strategically in order to be perceived
as uh someone who is qualified
and finally we have Society who includes
all people as a whole the goals of
society are very broad you strive for
fairness robustness to Bad actors uh and
increasing social welfare and the
actions that we can take is to regulate
and create public pressure
so whenever we talk about incentive
aware machine Learning Systems I'd like
to uh think about the whole ecosystem
and some of the research directions that
uh I've worked on is on the one hand
algorithms that are robust to incentives
where we have a very clear view of what
the behavior of the agents will be these
algorithms are from the institution
perspective
algorithms that not only are they robust
to agents strategizing according to a
very concrete behavioral model but also
they are robust to agents slightly
deviating from this behavioral model
because they can be like slightly
irrational
and uh importantly uh from the societal
perspective uh what are the effects of
algorithms that are non-transparent uh
in this whole ecosystem
uh that was all for me thank you very
much and then the next speaker will be
nilin abrahamson I'm sorry if I
butchered the name uh talking about
taming design problem of explicitly
anti-symmetrized neural networks via
foreign
and I'm interested in computational
problems from physics and chemistry okay
so I'm going to tell you about baking
symmetries into machine learning models
so our world is made up of particles
such as electrons and protons and we we
want to be able to simulate these in
order to better understand the molecules
and materials in our world
um and how do I want to simulate are the
uh the electrons
so if you take a physical system and you
rotate it then all the courses will also
be loaded
this is an example of a symmetry in
nature
and there's many more such symmetry
um the ones that I study are are the
ones that come from the quantum
mechanical nature of the world at the
chemical scales
um
so we need to we need to encode these
symmetries into our model in order to
make accurate predictions
suppose we have this molecule or atom
and we want to simulate it especially
the protons being heavy are are not a
big issue so let's focus on the
electrons
how would we represent these this
configuration in our computer
well let's try to say well one of them
is given by three coordinates so if we
have n of them then we can we can just
give three n coordinates
so
um so each block got three numbers in
this super in this set of numbers down
here represent one particle
so suppose we reshuffled these blocks in
our
within our table down here
that corresponds to a relabeling of the
particles
but to Nature this actually has no
meaning so the labels have no meanings
to Nature
so when we so these two different tables
of numbers represent the same political
system
and that's known as indistinguishability
of electron
so this wouldn't be a problem we could
just you know have our labeling and do
the simulation forget about the labels
at the end
except for the fact that this
configuration is not the actual state of
the system the actual state of the
system is a function on such
configurations
this function is known as the quantum
wave function
formerly the quantum wave function is
similar to a joint probability of
distribution
um so staying with this analogy
indistinguishability means that we need
a function uh on sets or but definitely
it's as a function on tables of numbers
a function on tables it's a symmetric or
permutation invariant function
uh this has been well studied and the
Machine learning literature recently
um for example deep set Construction
but uh but in our Quantum wave functions
of the electrons we have a slightly
different type of symmetry
known as anti-symmetry
and symmetry is not uh is not the
absence of symmetry but rather it's it's
a it's a more complicated type of
symmetry
okay so how do we encode this we want we
want to represent functions that satisfy
uh satisfy this anti-symmetry otherwise
we'll end up with solutions that have
are mean English physically
um
so you can actually take your random
function or your arbitrary function made
by your neural network and projected
onto the space around this metric
functions
um but this has all sorts of problems
for example uh it's inefficient so you
have too many terms that you can't
compute and you might also end up with
zero
so so we need to be smart about how we
do this and and we saw that you can
you can actually in second in certain uh
situations you can apply this by by
doing a transformation
all right so in conclusion you know we
have all we have all sorts of symmetries
in nature and we need to encode them in
our machine learning models
um
and um if you have any questions you can
email me so the next speaker is going to
be uh Soviet Dara
um we'll talk talk to you about
clustering and large Network thank you
very much
foreign
postdoc at MIT mathematics and Microsoft
so I am broadly interested in analyzing
large-scale networks and my background
is in applied probability I sort of like
to study probabilistic and statistical
questions on networks so today I'll be
giving you one example in graph
representation learning
so you can find graphs everywhere
nowadays these large networks if you
look at World Wide Web uh social
networks human brain so on uh
and these graphs are difficult to
analyze because there is internet
structure in the data right
over the past five years or so an
interesting idea that came up in the
graph in machine Learning Community is
the graph presentation learning what you
do is you learn some features about the
graph and use that feature to do your
prediction on the graph let's say you
have a social network for example and
you want to map each people in The
Social Network
to some point in the euclidean space and
your mapping should be such that uh
closeness in The Social Network or
people sharing similar features in the
social networks should give map closely
to each other in the euclidean space
once you have a mapping like this you
can use for different tasks such as
clustering link prediction anomaly
detection and so on
General ID and there are two algorithms
that have gained real popularity these
are deep work and not to work which
share similar ideas
but the idea is to First generate
multiple random walks in the graph so we
end up with a list of random walks deep
work uses simple random walks note to
make is more General Uses bias random
works you can think of it like Works in
not to work can have different
probability of going back to the
previous node for example
to have this list of random Works what
you do is apply some natural language
processing algorithm on that uh so for
example you can apply what to vac
algorithm uh and you can treat this
random works as sentences and the notes
as words okay once after this NLP
algorithm out comes an embedding for
Words which is notes in this case so you
have mapped your notes to euclidean
space successfully
so the interest for uh from our
perspective was to give a theoretical
ground for analyzing this algorithm and
come up with some wisdom that will tell
us that what kind of for example random
Works should we be using if you were
interested in clustering for example on
graphs
foreign
we have a communities in the graph right
and the edges are generated using some
independent process so these are
generated model uh and of course you
don't see the communities you see this
jump rate of graph and on this jumbled
up graph you'd run deep walk and note to
Vic outcomes and embedding you apply K
means clustering on that so that would
give you some clustering the question is
does this recover Community the most of
the vertices
and we answered this question for
example through a sequence of results
but the essential wisdom that comes out
is that if you are interested in
clusterity what you should do is you
should be using random walks that have
small backtracking probability as
compared to using simple random words
okay so for clustering is a global task
right so you want to explore your graph
more and more intuitively
therefore this non-back tracking Works
does a better job at doing clustered so
I'll be happy to chat about my other
interests in network science offline for
now that's what I have thank you for
your attention and the next speaker is
divyarthi
foreign
there but I'm also a research fellow
here for the semester of families
Institute and today I'll be talking
about my work which broadly lies at the
intersection of like algorithms
economics and Game Theory in particular
I like to think about like the effects
of like complex strategic interactions
in these regimes and figure out like how
we can tackle them both in like core
questions and mechanism design and also
thinking about models that are more like
practically relevant and like understand
practical phenomena that happens
um so I'll just like briefly give a
quick overview of like what I mean by
this today
um so yeah of course algorithms are
everywhere and moreover algorithms and
humans are like interacting more and
more in the modern world
um so algorithms are not just like
finding the best possible solution while
using resources efficiently in these
settings where for example you're using
algorithms to find a to match like
drivers with passengers or like using
algorithms to to drive like self-driving
cars in a busy City these algorithms
also face a very big new challenge which
is that they interact with strategic or
autonomous individuals that so modern
algorithms need to be aware of
incentives that like selfish or like
strategic agents have in order to be
even not just performed well but even
perform as intended and uh so we it's
important to understand the effects of
this strategic Behavior as well as like
design algorithms or mechanisms that are
robust to strategic behavior and
algorithmic mechanism design exactly
focuses on this uh it's a field where we
design mechanisms or algorithms that are
robust to strategic behavior and still
give good performance guarantees and my
work especially focuses on uh
multi-dimensional mechanism design that
is beyond the single dimensional
settings often even finding the optimal
mechanism is computationally intractable
and they are often prohibitively complex
so I tackle this through the lens of
approximation and study then and how we
can design simple mechanisms uh that are
robust to strategic behavior and give
provable performance guarantees and uh
more broadly uh the field of algorithmic
Game Theory uh tries to understand the
effects of strategic uh behavior and in
particular my work focuses on
understanding the interactions between
agents and like uh how they communicate
and learn from each other uh to
understand like very prevalent social
phenomena such as like polarization or
like misinformation information
propagation uh that happens and uh yeah
with that uh I I'll wrap up today the
next speaker is strong
um he's going to be talking about
translational neural networks
[Applause]
foreign
today I will share with you our
particular work on transmission neural
network transnet for short this is a
model that naturally links our models
with neural networks this is John to
work with speeder cans
uh if you think about how virus
propagate on a contact Network
um and each link exists between two
persons if they are within certain
radius for some period of time and the
multiple various particles that send
from one person to another if you use
aij to denote the number of particles
that's end and each of these particles
has some probability wij to successfully
transmit the virus and each node has a
state which is the probability of
infection denoted by TI given the
network structure given the current
status of the network we can write one
step prediction of the probability of
infection which is simply given in this
form so this is the type of individual
level by respect model on a contact
Network we can also interpret it as a
population level verse right where each
node represents the city and the
connections represent the traffic flows
among cities I can also think about this
as an information spread model on a
social network where the state Pi simply
represent the probability of certain
piece of information that the original
died
another interesting interpretation of
this model is look at as a neuronal
network at the neurotransmitter level
here this is a picture a typical
illustration of chemical synapse where
on the left the presently neuron after
excitation sends a large population of
these small molecules called
neurotransmitters into the synaptic clef
and each of these uh neurotransmitters
has a probability to successfully bind
with the postsynaptic neuron and then
cause the excitation of the
post-synaptic neuron so these are the
interpretations of the same Dynamics now
we want to facilitate the analysis
instead of associating a node with the
probability we associate with the new
state which is the summary information
of that node a big healthy
with this new view of the same model we
actually get a different representation
of the problem this form is nice because
now we have a linear summation of some
non-linear activity signal inputs where
this facile function we call it the
tunable log sigmoid activation function
it takes a tunable parameter W ranging
from zero to one represents the
activation level of that particular link
ranging from no pass partial pass to
Full Pass
uh here is an illustration of that theme
model the node operation is only linear
it's just taking a summation and each
node has a state which is the
information content and all the
non-linearities are associated with
links and each link uh have different
may have different activation level
parameter tablets this facilitate our
analysis to link discrete timers but
models we started with with the standard
Network sis model in continuous time
here and the
reasoning is as follows we first
identify the equivalent representation
of the same model with the different
state representation take the small time
limit we get a continuous timer version
of this transnet and use the Sim State
relation we recover the standard Network
SS model in continuous time which
represents the propagation of the
probability of infection over the
network
another type of result we can get is the
threshold condition which says that the
various on this characterized by this
model will die out regardless of the
initial conditions if the contact Matrix
the eigenvalues all the eigenvalues are
less than one in absolute value we also
established that this model are
Universal functional approximators in
particular with fixed sparse terms and
this is different from the standard
Universal function approximator where
the buyer's terms are also part of the
two number parameters on top of that we
get a set of tunable activation
functions we have a set of them and
their special case recover standard
activation function that's built
uh to conclude my talk here I present a
model that naturally links versus fat
models with neural networks and to view
the response model as neural networks
enables us to learn these parameters of
the thread models use the standard
neural network learning tools on the
other hand if you view the neural
network as a very respect model we get
natural interpretations of node being
active so that means that give us a
natural interpretation of the output of
the neural network so with that I want
to thank you for your attention
thank you
so the next speaker is Claire donut on
understanding the geometry of graph
neonates
thank you very much my name is currently
assistant professor in the department of
Statistics I think to Chicago and so I
want to talk today about some of the
work that we're trying to do on trying
to learn how to trust graph neural
networks so for a little bit of context
consider the problem of analyzing
network data so usually what happens is
you consider a graph with and non-mp
features like this one for instance and
you have an adjacency Matrix that
encodes the graph you have a bunch of
note features and typically you're
interested in a signal of Interest so
whether it's at the node level where if
you're doing no prediction regression or
Edge prediction so this is an example
not mine of for instance drug drug
interaction graph where you have
different types of nodes so drugs or
proteins and different types of edges
and you're trying to make sense of this
one and so the new trend in machine
learning is actually to try to tackle
these uh problems through graph neural
networks so essentially uh graph neural
networks are an adaptation of the deep
neural network Machinery to the graph
setting the crucial ingredients into
this adaptation is actually the spatial
convolution so what happens is um to try
and represent entire neighborhoods what
you do is essentially awaited some of
the node features over entire
neighborhoods and you use this weighted
sum
um through your the basic sort of neural
network Machinery so weight plus bias
and nonlinearity and you couple that
with some reconstruction objective of
some sort now
um essentially what this is all saying
is that you have an underlying manifold
right where some latent representation
exists and conditionally on that
relation representations you can sort of
generate the features and the adjacency
and dnns can be understood as a way of
recovering this uh latent representation
the problem that arises is that
graphical networks are very ill
understood and so um to be able to be
trustworthy and Deployable in real life
application you actually need a little
bit more sort of intuition as to what
happens and the topic that we're trying
to to do is understand actually how
they're estimating this underlying
manifold how they're trying to I guess
what are the properties of the manifold
that they're recovering and so I'll give
a quick highlight of what we're trying
to do for instance so in recent work
um for instance we try to analyze the
impact of the convolution operator and
so to this end we distinguish two
general families that are being used for
doing this convolution so symmetric
um family or pretty much what you do is
you take the adjacency you add a
self-loop beta and then you sort of you
know symmetrize it by dividing by the
degree of this augmented adjacency at
the power Alpha where Alpha is between
zero and one and the row normalized so
for instance cross stitches among this
family and the idea is okay so if we use
different convolution operator what is
the impact of them so this is not very
well understood in literature people
generally care about accuracy but not so
much the property of the manifold and
the reason why we're interested in these
two families is actually you can tie
them to better understood um objects for
instance diffusion maps that were
studied in the early 2000s so just to
show that actually matters so we've done
a couple of experiments for references
very Alpha so this is for the first time
mini for instance the one that is most
used in gnns you can see that the
performance of the accuracy actually
really depends on Alpha and this is
something that is really
um sort of you know pervasive across um
different data sets and you can also see
that they were normalized right so the
graph stage type of family is uh more
stable to understand exactly why this is
the case basically we um sort of phrased
the question as um variant to some
extent of the embedding and we're able
to show through simple computation that
the the variance of the embedding
actually is a function of Alpha and the
degree and so when Alpha is less than
degree this film is actually an
increasing sorry the alpha is less than
a zero five the bound is actually an
increasing function of degree and the
Opposites if Alpha is less than sorry
above zero five what this means is that
for low values of alpha typically you
have a situation where High degree nodes
have more variance so they're on the
Outsource of the data on the manifold
and for little degrees there at the
center right they're more they have
become very less and the up the the
process is uh opposite when uh you take
higher values of alpha this is not so
much the case for neuronormalized right
so the graph stage type of convolutions
so which are much more stable to the
degree and the value of Alpha and so
basically this is uh the quick just that
I wanted to give um today is um what
we're trying to do is understand the
properties of the the recovery the the
actual embeddings and tie them with
properties of the graph and the node
features uh to understand what the
manifold actually looks like and so this
is important because it highlights some
potential variety of the model for
instance you are giving more influence
to higher degree nodes in one case and
not the other and it also impacts the
ability of the model to capture more and
less structural roles with this I want
to end and thank you for your attention
oh
I guess the floor
can be predict like it's a Time series
of the people in different stages of Sir
process susceptible infections are
removed and if an outbreak happens can
we predict the size of it without like
knowing the whole network because that's
going to be costly so like the
traditional way to like answer this kind
of question is through Network model
which first we choose one of the
Thousand Network models that we can have
and then like we predict relevant uh
parameters for the model so for example
if we chose error training we have to
predict the average degree of the
network or if you choose configuration
rather than we have to predict the whole
degree sequence and in both steps we can
make mistakes and it's not really
um obvious what are the
misastication will result in like our
predictions and epidemics so in our work
we show that actually we don't need to
like have Network models instead like
obtaining local information about the
graph is enough to predict
um the time evolution of the epidemic
and also the finals as a final outbreak
just to give you an idea of what do I
mean by the local information
um we just use some algorithm that on a
high level just draws one node and runs
the info runs the infection in the back
for instance meaning that if I could
like reverse a client and what's the
chance that the random node is going to
be infected so it draws this random
nodes run it backwards see if it if it
in a few steps gets to an initially
infected node or not and if the answer
is yes it returns one and otherwise it
pretends zero and just the estimator
simplest measure is taking average over
all of them and you know with Christian
books and I'm in sabari we show that
actually just a constant number of
samples to this estimator with a
constant neighborhood is enough together
y minus Epsilon approximation of
epidemics and with that I'm going to
thank you for listening today and I
think this concludes the whole
researchable effects foreign
[Music]
to hear from our industry partners